please welcome machine gun kelly and his
wife actress megan fox
megan fox is a machine gun kelly's wife
just yet it's hard to top that one man
that's the engaged couple at the 2022
nba all-star game in cleveland over the
weekend and when they made it on the
jumbotron the announcer mistakenly
introduced them like this
please welcome machine gun kelly and his
wife actress megan fox yeah let's watch
that one more time please welcome
machine gun kelly and his wife actress
megan fox a source tells e.t that after
the announcement mgk didn't react to it
at all but megan started laughing and
you can see she said did they just call
me your wife it was very innocent and
cute what are my nicknames mgk machine
gun what are you what are your nicknames
for me oh is that what that means
buddha
lambie you haven't gotten that one in a
long while we gotta earn that one back
once the game started the two had a
blast the source says mgk spoke with a
lot of folks throughout the night and
was excited to see a lot of nba legends
that were there including magic johnson
and his wife cookie both couples were
spotted laughing and chatting together i
don't want to lose that feeling of
course megan and mgk aren't far away
from tying the knot after getting
engaged in january
source told et at the time megan and mgk
know that they are each other's soul
mates so they want to get married sooner
than later he's the most talented boy in
the world as far as how wedding planning
is going well our source says that they
want something very dark yet romantic
that shows off their lux and sexy sides
lots of black red and lace i love it
it's amazing clearly 2022 is shaping up
to be quite the year for the duo and
sharing in that happiness is megan's ex
brian austin green when mgk popped the
question a source told e.t brian is
happy for her but it really isn't
affecting him one way or the other
adding that there is no bad blood or ill
will between them at this point of
course the two were married from 2010 to
2021
and share three sons together noah bodie
and journey and now the beverly hills
90210 star will soon be a father to
another little one it's just beyond what
you would imagine would happen
it's like two people that you just never
expect would
would cross paths within a profession
doing so it's really
it's cool earlier this month brian and
his girlfriend dancing with the stars
pro sharna burgess announced they are
expecting a baby together the actor
shared this pic touching sharna's
growing bump writing in the caption we
are really excited to be welcoming a
baby boy on or around the 4th of july
sharna i cannot wait to see you hold
your slash our baby
[Music]
you